The Sunrise Seven is a group of chimps...
...from a wildlife refuge in California that closed in 2019.
We're really grateful to be able to say yes,...
...we can bring them to our sanctuary in Florida.
Save the Chimps is a nonprofit organization,...
...one of the largest chimpanzee sanctuaries in the world.
Bringing seven chimpanzees from California to Florida is not a small task.
We knew that FedEx Cares help nonprofits,...
...so we reached out and FedEx helped to transport the Sunrise Seven...
...as part of their Delivering for Good initiative.
The seven chimpanzees now have lifelong care at a loving home,...
...giving them the space to roam in natural habitats with other chimpanzees.
We can't wait to see who they are going to bond with, be best friends with.
It's our moral responsibility to care for these vulnerable beings.
They deserve a peaceful and safe retirement.